yeah so how come how come we're not i
mean look i saw the j and j
uh lawsuit that took place i think
started in 2019 uh
uh 2020 october 13th and then july 21st
uh drug distributors and j j reached 26
billion dollar deal to end opioids
lawsuits
do are you seeing a major progress being
made by both doctors because you you
give credit to four reasons why this is
taking place right it wasn't just let's
blame the pharmaceutical companies it
was four different things that you
talked about are you seeing this being
an issue that the folks at the top from
the politics or whoever holds them
accountable is bringing this up more are
they kind of looking the other way from
your experience
my experience is that um these
settlements that you're talking about
and if you look closely at the
settlements you'll see that how many
years that they're paid out over
and it's often times seven years
sometimes ten years
that they are making these you know
these restitution payments okay
but understand that they've made
billions and billions on their on their
drugs and they will continue to sell and
make billions while they're making these
payments so it's really just a yes the
number sounds big and you might say
what's better than nothing
but
it's a good business model i mean no
executives went to jail and none are
going to jail you know and the sacklers
the ones who own purdue pharma they just
got a bankruptcy settlement and said
earlier this month
they they are immune to civil litigation
for in perpetuity now they're there and
they get to keep over ha there are many
billions they've made they get to keep
all that and they never admitted
wrongdoing so
fines seems to be what pharmaceutical
companies do and is seen as the cost of
doing business and
it's a good business decision if you're
a pharmaceutical company or if you're a
board or a shareholder like yes you
market these drugs they're not really
approved for what you say they're using
but we're making a lot of money
eventually someone will impose a fee but
it'll be far less than than than what
we've made so that's that's a that's a
good business decision and what i want
to point out to you and some of your
viewers is that this is not the first
time that has happened
other drugs have had similarly been
marketed off label
and i'm referring to a drug called
neurontin here it's just a very famous
case
neurontin was marketed by pfizer as a a
drug for seizure disorder if you if the
other medicines weren't controlling it
but then it got off label marketed for
everything from headaches to adhd
and because of that it got so over
prescribed and made billions um
and they had to pay fines subsequently
as well uh several hundred million
dollars but if you paying 700 million
dollars on a drug you made billions uh
per year
that is a good business model you pay
the fine no executives go to jail the
shareholders are happy the only people
that get harmed are the patients
so
uh yeah so i'm looking at this well you
said the arrangement you're right under
this agreement the country's three
distributors would make payments of 21
billion dollars over 18 years johnson
and johnson would pay five billion over
nine years so it's chump change uh to
these guys and but can you go back to
the in in
perpetuity which means there is no lack
of accountability can you unpack what
that means
uh when they say it's in perpetuity so
if something happens if you can unpack
that for the rest of us what that means
is that according to all right and i i
am not a i can't i can't claim to be a
bankruptcy legal expert okay
but according to the stories i have read
about the bankruptcy filing in the state
of new york for purdue pharma the
sacklers have been absolved of
wrongdoing and they may not be held
accountable
for any future civil litigation due to
the harm of their product that they
cause through exposing them even
irresponsibly um
and remember if purdue pharma had to pay
had to pay hundreds of millions back in
like 2007
for irresponsible marketing of their
product even then so this is there's
nothing new about the irresponsible
marketing they've and then they they
basically they got away with it
so but here's so that's what it means is
that how can they do that though who
allows them to do that are these
politicians who are helping them do that
who allows these contracts to be written
in a way where they're protected
it it has to do with the how the
bankruptcy laws are written and they are
written true by politicians but but
remember that politicians are writing
these laws that are often made put
together by the lobbyists that represent
the corporate business interests so they
make the laws very favorable
to the business interests sure sure
and so that then you then you can now
you've got the law in the books and
you're like hey we'd like to do
something but this you know we can't
because here's how it's written now and
i'm like yeah
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]